Film Courage: Jeff, what is an enneagram and
how does it help a writer create complex characters?
Jeff Kitchen, Dramatist / Author / Founder
/ Consultant: The enneagram is a really valuable
tool.
It's a personality profiling system that is
a mix of ancient wisdom about human nature
and cutting-edge psychology.
I was introduced to it by a friend of mine
who was a top psychiatrist in New York City
and he was a good friend and he loved movies
so he loved to consult on projects that I
was working on so like if I was developing
a script with a client I would often bring
him in.
One time I brought the actor John Leguizamo
to him he was working on a murder story and
he wanted some in-depth stuff the kind of
stuff that Armand could bring and he met with
Armand and I talked to John afterwards and
Armand had sat him down in front of police
video of a guy who had just murdered his parents
45 minutes beforehand.
This was real footage and john said Oh my
gosh it messed me up.
I was like I couldn't sleep that night and
I was like whoa and I said well was it good
research?
He goes off top shelf like off the charts
crazy and I worked with Armand a lot that
way and at one point he said to me because
he was doing character profiles on these at
one point he said to me Have you ever checked
out the enneagram?
It's the best thing out there.
I'd never heard of it before and coming from
him he was really brilliant and really at
the top of his game and for him to say it's
the best thing out there i was like whoa it
wasn't like oh i think i'll check it i was
like boom i was like right on it and i studied
it intensively for a couple years and it what
it it purports that there's nine basic personality
types and each of them has their own uh basic
fears basic desires motivations preferences
tendencies weaknesses flaws and there's all
these different and not only all that but
each of the nine types has different aspects
like they're either a healthy aspect an average
aspect or an unhealthy aspect and depending
on what shape you're in emotionally and psychologically
you are your life is either coming together
you're you're integrating or your life is
falling apart you're disintegrating and if
you if you are coming together as a person
emotionally and psychologically then you will
tend to exhibit the average to healthy aspects
of the type you are
if you are falling apart as a person then
you will tend to exhibit the average to unhealthy
aspects of that personality type so it is
a um and they say that the average person
flickers between all those all day long where
you can have extremely healthy reactions or
actions in certain situations or extremely
unhealthy and you flicker back and forth all
day long like real people in and out of different
emotional states and so on but you will tend
to be what you are in other words if you tend
to be healthy then most of your stuff will
tend to be average to healthy and it is a
so like the nine types are like um they give
them labels but they don't use the labels
very much type 1 they call the reformer type
2 is the helper type 3 is the achiever type
4 is the individualist type 5 is the thinker
or the they have different names type six
is the loyalist type seven is the enthusiast
type eight is the leader or the challenger
type nine is the peacemaker but because each
of those labels has certain connotations with
different people the people who work with
it professionally they'll call you a one or
a four or a seven because it's context free
in a certain way the labels don't bring their
own misunderstandings to people who are less
skilled in the application of the of the technique
so that like a type three the achiever can
be very high performing it'll be like a tony
robbins type where they really work hard to
actualize all their best capabilities tom
cruise is a type three people who can really
achieve great things push themselves to be
the best they can be and can really be extraordinary
but in the unhealthy or in the average aspects
they can be really concerned with how they
appear they're constantly wanting to look
good even if they aren't doing well emotionally
in the unhealthy aspects they can actively
lie to look good even when they're in really
rough shape they're really over concerned
with how they appear and will do even devious
things to maintain that appearance so that
in the extremely unhealthy aspects they can
even be suicidal or murderous to maintain
the illusion of their superiority or achieve
their achievements even if they're not there
so
in terms of the
in both the creation of a character and the
development and dimensionalization of a character
these the the the basic human nature which
is built into the study of the enneagram and
the cutting edge psychology which is built
into it inform
what you both find in your character and can
create in your character for instance if i
uh like for instance going back to your it
guide derek and the young woman skyler uh
i would one of the things i'd be looking at
and i'd be doing that once i get a dilemma
up and running i'm also looking in the early
stages of developing a dilemma for derek i
would go very quickly to which enneagram type
is he because that's going to inform so much
who he is and how he interacts with his dilemma
and what his basic fears and basic desires
and tendencies and motivations and disabilities
and flaws and blind spots all of that inform
not only what the dilemma is but how he will
interact with it because of his basic fears
and drives and all that so let's see if i'm
looking at him might he be a one the reformer
it's possible two the helper maybe three the
achiever possible for the individual list
possible because he is an individualist can
be uh intuitive artistic want to sort out
their own emotions before they deal with anything
else uh possibly a type five a thinker a you
know someone who is perfecting things before
they launch out sherlock holmes was a type
5 wants to have everything like a type 4 wants
to figure out their emotional stuff before
they move ahead a type 5 wants to figure out
the mechanics of a situation and have a lot
of knowledge because their basic fear is that
they're not well prepared so they're protecting
themselves so they want to know everything
before they take a step so they spend too
much time figuring out before they take action
so they can be extremely world-changing when
they're on top of their game and see things
in a completely fresh way but they can also
be paranoid and reclusive and dissociated
from who they really are because they're desperately
trying to figure it all out in their head
before they do their debut um so maybe he's
a five he could be a sixth the loyalist which
is lends itself to the it was the guard watchdog
for this mainframe and the whole company the
type one of the main motivating factors in
a type six is they are constantly hoping that
the next person they latch onto is going to
be the one who can show them how to navigate
life successfully are you the one can you
help me learn how to make my life work which
see that goes with the watchdog for the corporation
but also skyler like are you the one that's
going to show me how to make my life work
finally so a six is a possibility a four is
a possibility because the um a four is inwardly
tuned has a lot of artistic sensitivities
and a lot of inner debate and wants to
make things work at an emotional level uh
i'm not describing it accurately enough but
this is really an overview too but a four
is an interesting possibility for derrick
a six is an interesting possibility a seven
the enthusiast is the busy fun-loving type
which could be a very interesting possibility
for uh skyler someone who's like wildly enthusiastic
the life of the party always busy a healthy
seven is a lot of fun an unhealthy seven can
be a drug addict they're a constant escapist
mode a seven's main motivation is to um in
the unhealthy aspect of their fears they wanna
they wanna what's the word kind of dispel
unease they can't sit and deal with emotional
complexity they want to escape from it they
they don't have the the bone that enables
them to sit there and figure it out they're
in escape mode a lot if they're average to
unhealthy so they're always looking for the
next thing they're always planning even if
they've spent three months planning a big
cruise with all their friends they can't enjoy
the cruise because they're busy planning the
next thing it's always about their plans but
they can be really fun to be around and a
healthy seven is really fun and a really healthy
happy integrated person so i would think that
she's gonna be pretty unhealthy but they look
dazzlingly fun especially to someone who is
feeling miserable and trapped and caught in
a rut and no way out so it's kind of an interesting
chemical connection where her malfunction
meshes with his malfunction in a way that
she looks like his savior and he may look
like her savior so they sink on a lot of levels
and
they fit each other's compulsive pattern in
a certain way that even though it's an unhealthy
relationship they get a lot of mileage out
of it before the each realizes that wow i'm
back where i started or worse because he's
just as messed up as i am in a completely
different way and we really screwed this thing
up you know it's that kind of thing so in
many ways it's a mixture of what you bring
to the picture with your story and what the
enneagram offers as possibilities for character
traits and possibilities for character
you you when you come with your story you
have
a certain amount of something already you're
not coming with nothing and just looking at
the enneagram for instance with the story
of derek
you've already got a raw story and we've done
some work with dilemma so you've got him trapped
and then if you find that he seems like a
type six enneagram then the tendencies and
basic fears and all the things that make up
a six influence your story and your story
influences how you use those parts of the
enneagram for instance if you are looking
at the mechanics of a type 6
and it offers some dynamic possibilities for
what derek might be like as he falls apart
in a crucial moment of the story then that
could really inform the story choices that
you make and the story choices that you make
can inform what parts of the enneagram you
use or amplify or play with you know so much
of it is an experimental mix as you're really
working with everything to gel that which
you decide to run with one of the key ways
that i use the enneagram is that if you've
got a story idea that's up and running and
you've worked on dilemma then that's a point
as as you begin to get into dilemma for your
protagonist that's when it's very useful to
look at the enneagram because the the character
traits of the type of your protagonist the
personality type will inform and influence
your insight into the dilemma it can suggest
possibilities it can deepen and dimensionalize
the dilemma and the way that i tackle that
is that i'll have that character in mind like
derek and then i'll look at the one sheet
for each of the nine types and those come
from the um enneagram institute.com website
i work with a slightly older one sheet from
when i wrote my book around 2006.
it it fits on one sheet of paper and it has
a lot of information what they have for their
one sheet now is they've expanded upon it
so there's more complexity which is great
i just like going back to the one sheets that
are in my book writing a great movie because
it's short and sweet then once you've worked
with that you'll find the stuff on their website
which opens it up a little more to be very
useful too but what i do is that i think i
put myself in the position of my character
or i think about my character the lead character
and look at the one sheet for each of the
nine types and i'll sometimes just use my
book or i often i print out the one sheets
because i've saved them and i'll look at a
type one thinking about derek and be like
okay silver former there's some key aspects
maybe a couple on my underline that's a maybe
look at the two go through that three oh that
has more stuff that's interesting four has
some distinct possibilities five and you know
and maybe when i'm looking at a five well
even while i'm thinking about derek i may
notice that wow that could really be the the
predator who's operating skyler and it just
jumps out at me like wow there's there's that
person so you're just kind of like going through
the nine one sheeps nine one sheets mostly
one character at a time but sometimes other
ones will just jump out at you and
so i found that i think derek really seems
like a six and kind of like this you know
as you're looking through the one sheet a
whole bunch of stuff starts to light up for
you and then once you've figured out who your
main characters are which type your main characters
are even if you have a couple possibilities
like at first you're not sure you think derek
might be a four or a six and you play with
that for a while and then usually your understanding
of it will crystallize after a while where
perhaps you see how derek reacts in a key
moment and that really resonates with a tendency
of a type six and then you really see yeah
i really think he is a type six not a type
four so your gra your understanding gradually
crystallizes at first it's tentative and you
keep the possibilities open because you're
not trying to force any of these types on
your characters you're just trying to
listen to who your characters are and listen
to what the enneagram is saying as possibilities
for them which type they might be and so on
but after a while you will um your understanding
will crystallize and at that point it's really
interesting to go to the book the wisdom of
the enneagram
which is written by the same guys from the
enneagram institute and it's a big thick book
and there's a 40 page chapter on each type
which takes you much much deeper than the
one sheet did and it really goes so deep into
so many aspects of that character type that
it helps you dimensionalize them
it shows the reasons why these tendencies
are there and why their fear is there and
the way in which they fall apart when things
really go bad for them and the way in which
they can go from being in an extremely unhealthy
reactive state to a healthy proactive integration
where they they can pull themselves together
and become a healthy aspect of themselves
you know and scripts deal with character arcs
so where a person's flaws and weaknesses and
disabilities and all that are either resolved
if there's a creative resolution and they
become a more healthy version of themselves
or they disintegrate and become
you know fall apart completely in in a tragic
resolution but the uh the 40 page chapter
is really a deep and complex journey through
the full mechanics of what makes this person
tick and it really gives you tremendous depth
and dimension and flaws and strengths and
hopes and subconscious attitudes and how they
react in a bad situation and how they can
pull themselves out of a tail spin in certain
types of situations so it really is very comprehensive
and one of the things that's most interesting
about working with the enneagram is that i've
done it hundreds of times for so many different
characters and
for instance when i'm going through the 40
page chapter for a character that's maybe
a five maybe i've already done 15 different
characters that are fives and really studied
them in depth and really know them well but
maybe one was like a serial killer in you
know the bombings of ireland and one is a
you know a schizophrenic baker in argentina
and like completely like comedy and so that
the characters come in such completely different
contexts that when i start going back through
something that i've been through a whole whole
bunch of times like the 40 page chapter on
a type 5 it's like i've never seen it before
because it's completely different because
i'm inhabiting this baker now instead of this
bomber and it's literally like i've never
seen this stuff before which is so interesting
because i've been soaking my head in it for
years so it's fresh each time which is great
because that's what you want when you're developing
characters it's not just a rehash of people
you already know but a completely fresh discovery
from a completely new character and you're
not only are you pulling new material out
of what you've already been through but your
facility with the tool grows and expands each
time so you know you just have more facility
more ability to understand more complexities
and also the ability to just see it more simply
and clearly like oh it's just that instead
of like it's all this stuff so you you know
your your capacity to work with the tool both
clarifies and deepens into more complexity
because sometimes the ability to just see
thing clearly and simply is the aha moment
that you've been working toward maybe for
years in terms of using this tool where you
start to understand the different personality
types more clearly even if you have to work
hard to get there each time but you're a little
better at it each time and yet it's always
new that's endlessly fascinating
okay so that's a good tour through the enneagram.
Questions For The Viewers: Have you ever used
the enneagram to help you write characters?
How do you like this tool?